on parle avec vous billy burke ragga
kiev bonjour à vous believer comment
sont perçus ces sanctions
internationales du point de vue
l'ukrainien
je pense qu'il est clair pour tout le
monde que les sanctions introduit ou
annoncés jusque là ne sont pas encore le
package sanction sans précédent que joe
biden avait menacé en cas d'invasion
russe de l'ukraine mais l'invasion aussi
pour le moment n'est pas cette invasion
massive pour le moment les troupes
russes il a été annoncé qu'ils entreront
dans les territoires actuellement
contrôlée par les séparatistes donc des
territoires que la russie contrôlent
defacto déjà depuis 2014 ce n'est pas
exactement la même chose selon certains
que d'envahir la partie de l'ukraine que
le gouvernement ukrainien contrôle mais
il est clair que l'ukraine attend plus
en terme de sanction si la russie va
plus loin ce que la plupart des gens ici
craignent mais le président volodymyr
zelensky est vraiment entré dans un mode
où il comprend que leur de critiquer les
alliés occidentaux de l'ukraine est
passé il faut maintenant rallier et
rassurer le peuple donc dans son
allocution hier soir il a été plus à se
féliciter du succès de ces pourparlers
il a dit qu'il avait parlé avec les
leaders des états unis du royaume uni de
l'europe et caetera et à la sortie de
chaque conversation téléphonique il y a
eu un résultat en terme d'une action en
termes de sanctions qui ont été
appliquées et puis bien sûr pour
l'ukraine le vrai test ou le premier
test si vous voulez de la détermination
de l'occident à soutenir l'ukraine
c'était la question de est ce que
l'allemagne va enfin annulé le gazoduc
nordstream de annulé la certification de
ce gazoduc qui relie la russie à
l'allemagne eh bien ils l'ont fait et
donc ça c'est un soulagement pour les
ukrainiens sinon j'ai parlé aussi à un
habitant de chasse tient sur la ligne de
front ville qui a été bombardé hier et
qui pourrait être le premier cible des
soi-disant séparatistes ils veulent
reprendre du territoire je lui ai
demandé qu'est ce qu'il pensait des
sanctions il m'a dit je ne peux pas
commenter cela au téléphone parce que je
suis sûr qu'on est sous écoute
visiblement il pensait qu'il n'était pas
sous abri de passer sous contrôle russe
gulliver bonjour le cren continue à se
préparer à une guerre
oui aussi dans son message aux
ukrainiens hier soir volodymyr zelensky
a parlé de la nécessité de soutenir
l'économie ukrainienne pour que
l'économie puisse soutenir et financer
l'armée donc l'armée qui bien sûr va
avoir besoin de plus d'argent il y à la
mobilisation des réservistes et donc en
parallèle à cette mobilisation des
réservistes volodymyr zelensky a annoncé
une mobilisation du gouvernement pour
soutenir l'économie différentes
programme pour stimuler la production
ukrainienne est ce qu'il a appelé le
patriotisme économique
merci glover en direct de qui avait
l'otan de son côté s'attend